[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the topic of taxation comes
up on the program a lot and the reason
it comes up is because taxes are both a
political issue and an economic issue
and a social issue when it comes to what
our society's priorities via taxation
and who we want to be taxing so just as
like some examples for you we've talked
about what is the tax rate that
maximizes revenue for the government and
who should be taxed at what rate in
order to obtain the maximum amount of
revenue before tax has become a
disincentive to productivity how do
certain tax plans impact people on the
basis of the amount of money that they
make have tax cuts and tax increases
historically help the economy or hurt
the economy and how do we measure it is
it better for the economy to cut or
raise taxes on the rich what about on
the poor what about the middle class
supply side versus demand side we've
talked about all of those things before
and I'm not going to talk about any of
those things today okay what I'm going
to focus in on today is the legal basis
for taxation in the United States not
generally the legal basis for taxation
around the world or as a concept but in
the United States what is the legal
basis for taxation now you might wonder
if you're a reasonable person why the
hell are you going to talk about that
obviously it's legal for the government
to tax people well it might be obvious
to you but there are people to whom it
is not obvious this relates to the group
that says taxation is theft or the
government is stealing or even that
taxation is actually illegal and it's
good to know exactly how to respond
because the real conversations we should
be having are the ones we've been having
on the show that I mentioned
two minutes ago but to get to that point
you need to get past the objections that
some people have which are that taxes
are just straight-up illegal so first of
all I can't refute every version of the
there's no law that says you have to pay
taxes argument because there are dozens
and dozens of versions of that argument
but I'm gonna lay out a general
framework for you that will at least
give you a starting point to talk to
people when they make these assertions
so we'll start with the legal portion
then we'll talk about the ideological
portion which is more the idea of taxes
being theft the general right to collect
taxes is in the Constitution
specifically it's in the sixteenth
Amendment of the Bill of Rights and it
says quote the Congress shall have power
to lay and collect taxes on incomes from
whatever source derived without
apportionment among the several states
and without regard to any census or
enumeration the key word there is
incomes what counts as taxable incomes
well for information on that we go to
the united states code of law twenty-six
subsection 63 which says that taxable
income is simply gross income minus
allowed deductions tax law enumerates
what deductions are available to people
this includes stuff like the mortgage
interest deduction or loss carryovers
all of these different things that we
talk about on a year-to-year basis and
that's how your income is defined so
that gets us to you must pay taxes all
right that is in the Constitution and
that's in the United States code of law
but some people will argue where does
the law say that you have to file a tax
return every year what about that
element well we also go to the United
States code of law for that United
States code 26 subsection 6 0 1 2 which
requires the filing of tax returns by
every individual who has gross income
for the year and there are dozens and
dozens of legal cases that have upheld
this so now
I know that this is so general that
there will be anti-tax people who will
write to me and they'll say David you
know what you're ignoring when you tell
us about this are the technicalities or
the semantics or particular wordings
that they assert prove taxation is
illegal but the bottom line is as a
general framework when people say
there's no law that says the government
can collect taxes the sixteenth
amendment
plus the United States code of law plus
dozens of cases worth of legal precedent
laid out very very clearly
constitutional law scholars pay their
taxes because they know that it's legal
accountants pay their taxes because they
know that they have to economists pay
their taxes taxation is legal so let's
now move on to the sort of more
ideological political argument that
taxes are theft okay the main argument
is that taxation is theft because you
don't have a choice about paying taxes
if you don't pay your taxes men with
guns as they like to say will show up
and put you in jail or prison it's an
initiation of force and therefore
taxation is theft in the ideological
political sense but number one men with
guns is an argument for improper
initiations of force is silly in and of
itself I don't want to focus on that
piece today because I feel like it's not
really central to what we're really
trying to figure out here there is a
social contract which includes taxation
enforcing taxation by the government is
merely enforcing that contract now
anti-tax libertarians will say I never
signed that contract how can I be party
to a contract that I never signed or
agreed to participate in well actually
you did okay one possibility is that
your parents chose for you to live in
the United States after you were born
they have power of custody that's the
law and you therefore are part of the
social contract that is the United
States of America because of the
decision your parents made when they had
custody of you and you can leave in any
time if you can find another country
that will have
that relates to the law of other
countries not to the United States
if you emigrated to the United States
you signed the contract called the USA
when you took your oath of citizenship
you swore to uphold our laws which
include taxation as described into the
Constitution sixteenth Amendment and the
United States called coat code of law if
you're not a citizen but you're here as
a permanent resident or on a Visa or
with a green card you did the exact same
thing as part of receiving that
apparatus which allows you to be in the
United States legally the fact that you
may not have physically signed it is
really meaningless if you go to a
restaurant and order food would it be
valid to say I don't really owe the
restaurant any money because I didn't
sign a contract no that would be a
really dumb argument it would be a
childish libertarian argument and that's
exactly the argument that they are
making when they say that taxation is
theft now let's go to the next part of
their argument which is that you don't
have the option not to pay taxes to the
American government that's also not true
and it really comes down to what do you
mean by options if you truly don't want
to pay taxes to the United States
government for whatever reason you have
the option of not working that's your
call how you survive would be up to you
to figure out in a libertarian paradise
but it is your call if you don't want to
pay taxes one way is not to have any
income number two you can leave the
country now as I mentioned you would
then be subject to the laws of other
countries in terms of whether you could
even live and work in those countries
and by the way other countries also have
taxes so that would be sort of a
practical limitation you can also lobby
to have the law changed so that there
are no more taxes now I think it would
be difficult to do that because most
people understand that we need taxes
humans not in a state of nature working
in groups that are bigger than a hundred
and fifty people to pick a sort of
evolutionary relevant number need taxes
there's simply no other way to carry out
a lot
of these basic mechanisms for human life
so I think it would be difficult to go
ahead and convince enough of the
population that we don't need taxes but
you could also Lobby to have the law
change you could lobby your elected
officials or whoever else and then
number four you could also just take a
chance on not paying your taxes and see
if you get caught maybe you wouldn't
that would certainly be a choice that
you would have to make so taxes are not
illegal the sixteenth amendment the
United States code of law lay all of
that out and taxes are also not theft
you have a number of different options
if you don't want to pay taxes to the
United States of America this is
relevant shockingly because there is a
surprisingly high portion of
libertarians that believe this now I
know that lots of sane libertarians will
say I'm really more of a social
libertarian I a constitutional
libertarian or they will apply civil
libertarian other words to it but there
are libertarians that believe this stuff
and you have to get past this in order
to get to what I consider to be the
really important questions about
taxation meaning what should be the
priorities of taxation who should be
paying taxes how much should they be
paying and how should that money be
spent and what the society most benefit
benefit from the usage of those taxes on
if I'm missing something if you think
that the legal framework that I've laid
out is not sufficient to defend taxation
as a legal mechanism I want to hear from
I'm on Twitter at Dee Pakman and the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
let me know and I will be more than
willing to have my mind changed if you
make a coherent and compelling argument
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is Trevin ples Trevon thank you I really
appreciate your support also want to say
thanks to John Sheehan John Sheehan is
today's Hall of Fame longtime sustaining
member of the day
John's been with us for almost five
years
Trevon and John thank you if you like
the work that we do if you think that
the work we do is worth just a couple of
pennies for each video that we upload to
YouTube or 30 cents for every hour
podcast that we do it's not a lot of
money go to WWE and pac-man comm select
the membership you can discount the
membership of your choice with the
coupon code this is 20/20 this is to
zero to zero it'll save you 40% it drops
a yearly membership to just 36 dollars
it drops a monthly membership to just
three dollars and sixty cents and it
goes a long way to support the work that
we do it allows us to distribute the
program at no cost to two hundred radio
and television stations it allows us to
make the program available on a dozen or
so platforms at this point free of
charge to everybody who wants it
so this matters this actually makes a
difference ww join pakman.com patreon
also available at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we have a david pakman
show subreddit on reddit it is one of
the biggest subreddits of any
progressive political show approaching
10,000 subscribers and I encourage you
to go to david pakman.com slash reddit
see what all the hubbub is about
subscribe participate in the discussion
I noticed this morning when I was
looking at the subreddit a post about
the frequency of the fake David Pakman
quotes a user says hey moderators you
should probably shut down the fake quote
meme maybe some of these are funny as
inside jokes
but putting a bunch of images online
associating fake quotes with David
Pakman name and face isn't much
different from actively spreading this
information about his views I am kind of
mixed on this Pat will put up a few of
the examples of these fake David quotes
for people to take a look at I agree
that it would be potentially damaging
for things I haven't actually said to be
put on these quote images and sent
around the internet they could be
misinterpreted as things that I actually
said but they're also really really
funny and often deal with the fact that
when people call in to the show we can't
hear them or they're on speakerphone or
it sounds like they're in the middle of
a war zone so I understand the concern
Pat but they're also really really funny
and they do reference some pretty clever
inside jokes including when I say that
we're going to edit out an entire
portion of the show where something
mildly embarrassing happens even though
we do the show as if it's a live show so
we don't actually do that I get the
concern but I think overall it's pretty
damn funny yeah you don't want to see
what actually gets cut out from the show
we're gonna hide that forever I think
it's funny I think the humor outweighs
the potential for people to think that
you actually said those things so I say
let's keep it going let's keep it going
yeah I like it as well and like you're
pointing out the things that we actually
edit out we would never even joke about
it we just make it disappear and it ends
up not even on the cutting room floor it
ends up in the recycle bin of Pat's
computer and then removed never to be
found again so anyway I get it but I
think it's a pretty funny gag also from
the david pakman show subreddit um
crisis averted
hillary clinton makes it official she's
not running in 2020 I never really
thought that Hillary Clinton was going
to run in 2020 I know that there was a
brief moment in time where I think
something she said was asserted to mean
that she hadn't made a decision one way
or the other but I don't know about you
pat it never struck me as credible that
Hillary Clinton was going to be running
again for president this coming election
well the best case that she has for
making another run is that she won the
popular vote in two
sixteen by three million votes I would
say though the worst case that she has
the thing that's strongest against her
is the fact that her popularity right
now is lower than Donald Trump's how
that is possible still I have no idea
but definitely a good decision
don't run again yeah I think it's the
right decision I think that Hillary
Clinton running again in 2020 would have
created three or four different layers
of issues the relationship to the DNC
would be one piece even if the DNC has
quote reformed to some degree the fact
that there is to whatever degree you
believe the DNC was favoring Hillary
Clinton and I know that our audience
disagrees about what that degree is but
I don't think anybody could say that
there was no degree to which the DNC
favored Hillary Clinton that's a problem
number two there's always this idea of
do you want to run someone coming off of
a loss that's a question around a bit
better or roark candidacy there are a
whole bunch of different questions
around that and the number three is Pat
is pointing out Hillary Clinton is even
less popular now than she was at the
time of the 2016 election based on one
poll that I saw a polls may conflict'
about that so I think that this is the
right decision I don't find that this is
surprising at all
and the biggest question now that
remains is is Joe Biden going going to
run I see Joe Biden Pat as the kind of
centrist establishment person that would
be similar to Hillary Clinton in terms
of the role he plays within the
Democratic Party but I don't know if you
agree with that I do agree with that and
if Joe Biden decides not to run than I
think camallo Harris would take that
position that would be her the
establishment choice I do think Biden
will run though especially because he's
almost at the top of every poll right
now
so in a way it would be silly for him
not to run we will see whether Joe runs
and no more discussions about Hillary
Clinton 2020 she's not running she said
it much to the chagrin or delight of
different people depending on who you
like and what your politics are she's
not running and I think we're ready to
move on join the discussion on the
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT
there are two economic issues that I
want to talk about with you today which
people are often confusing with each
other and Donald Trump actually seems
very very confused about the two on the
one hand you have the federal budget
deficit on the other hand you have the
national trade deficit these are two
different things and historically Donald
Trump has confused the two I don't want
you confusing them because if you do
it's going to be very difficult to have
a productive conversation about either
of them if we're not properly
distinguishing them so as a sort of
refresher the budget deficit is how much
the federal government spends versus how
much it takes in if the government
spends more than it takes in that's a
deficit if the government spends less
than it takes in that's called a surplus
on policy Donald Trump promised that he
was going to slash the budget deficit
because of all the growth and winning
and all of that stuff federal budget
deficit on the other hand you've got the
national trade deficit the national
trade deficit is how much we export
versus how much we import if you export
more you have what's called a trade
surplus if you import more you have
what's called a trade deficit the United
States has had a trade deficit for a
long time I mean since the mid-70s as
measured today the numbers are very very
clear and that trade deficit has grown
pretty significantly over time other
than some reductions towards the
beginning of Barack Obama's presidency
Donald Trump promised to get us a trade
surplus including with China and in fact
part of Donald Trump's reasoning for
doing the tariff program with China was
that he believed it would help to reduce
the trade deficit with them and maybe
even get us closer to a surplus so let's
talk about both of these issues federal
budget deficit national trade deficit
based on new numbers that we now have
which are an absolute and total disaster
based on what Donald Trump promised and
based on what the American right-wing
claims to want first let's talk about
the budget deficit the budget deficit
has grown seventy-seven percent in the
first four months of fiscal year 2019
compared to appear
a year ago which was already bigger in
2018 than in 2017 a year ago the first
four months had a deficit of a hundred
and seventy six billion dollars in the
first four months of fiscal year 2019
that has grown from 176 billion to 310
billion dollars of deficit why has this
happened I've mentioned this before tax
cuts for the rich combined with spending
increases building on already existing
deficits just makes the deficit bigger
rather than smaller now if you want to
argue with me that hey David the deficit
doesn't matter or the deficit only
sometimes matters depending on why we
are deficit spending I'm actually with
you that's a great discussion to have
it's a discussion that I wish
Republicans were having honestly since
decades ago when they became focused on
the deficit and became deficit hawks but
that's not what Trump thinks and it's
not what Republicans believe they are
hypocrites Trump made promises the
promise was to cut the deficit and the
opposite has happened it is absolutely
exploded now you could also make the
argument that the raw numbers like the
total number of deficit dollars isn't
important because if the country keeps
growing and the economy keeps growing
you have to adjust the deficit to
account for that as a percentage of the
GDP but the GDP adjusted deficits are
still deficits and Trump promised a
surplus so the guy is still a hypocrite
and a liar that's the budget deficit
okay let's now go to the trade deficit
we have 2018 trade deficit numbers and
they're the highest ever 891 billion
dollars in merchandise trade deficit and
621 billion dollars in services trade
deficit adjusting that for inflation and
economic growth that is a new record
trade deficit I was thinking finally
Donald Trump can claim to have a bigger
one than Barack Obama and be telling the
truth usually when he says that it's
actually a lie the trade deficit we knew
that
he was terrifying China it wasn't going
to reduce the trade deficit it was
actually going to increase it and it did
we knew that when he was talking about
the renegotiations of NAFTA and other
trade agreements that the entire way
Trump was conceiving of it or more
accurately said misconceiving of it was
not going to reduce the trade deficit it
was going to increase it and that's
exactly what we are seeing so when we
talk about this Pat I'm trying to be
clear and I hope I'm I'm being clear I
hope I'm succeeding it being clear that
there are really important conversations
to have about whether budget deficits
are good or bad or whether it depends
there are conversations to be had about
is it even realistic for the American
economy as structured to have a trade
surplus right now or do we just need to
accept that we're going to have a trade
deficit and that that's okay that's all
reasonable that's not what I'm talking
about here what I'm talking about here
is the completely unrealistic promises
made by Donald Trump which he has failed
to keep and if if Trump had done nothing
these numbers would be a lot better and
I think it just has to do with the fact
that priorities have shifted Republicans
claimed that they were all for lowering
the deficit in the past and it sounds
like now they're more interested in
passing tax cuts they're more interested
in raising military spending so their
priorities have shifted and when it
comes to the the trade deficit I think
Trump priorities prioritizes looking
strong in alpha and renegotiating trade
deals over lowering the trade deficit if
he changed his priorities maybe these
numbers would shift I would actually
argue that it's not that their
priorities have actually shifted it's
that when they claim their priority is
reducing the deficit it's just not
genuine I think that their priorities
have actually stayed the same and it's
that they lie when they say we
absolutely must reduce the deficit as
far as the public perception of this
you've got the deficit trolls who claim
to actually want to prioritize reducing
the deficit when it's a Democrat in the
White House and then all of a sudden
they don't care when it's a Republican
on the trade deficit I don't think that
if you ask the average not even just
Republican I think if you ask the
average voter are we better off with
trade deficit or a trade surplus and why
I think three to five percent of
Americans could actually answer that and
so it's a political issue that Trump has
successfully used to convince people he
knows what he's talking about but most
people don't even understand why it
matters and when that's the case when
they don't even have a false notion like
with the federal budget deficit a lot of
voters have a notion albeit a false one
about why it matters and why they think
we need to reduce the deficit with the
trade deficit I genuinely think they
have no idea and that's how you end up
with this sort of weaponization of
ignorance and talking points from a
candidate that even himself doesn't
understand what's going on and
unfortunately it works it works on the
American public and trade was one of
these issues that Trump actually in the
pre-election period appealed to his base
within to the Republican base with the
numbers though absolute record huge
deficits trade deficit and federal
budget deficit will there be any
consequences for Trump on that basis as
usual probably not make sure to follow
me on instagram at David Pakman lot of
funny stuff posted there I invite you to
follow me and I'll keep posting funny
stuff the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Daniel M Irv R who is teaching
history at Northwestern University also
is the author of the recent book how to
hide an empire a history of the greater
United States Daniel thanks for joining
me first of all I think this is such an
important topic right now for a few
different reasons number one just
understanding the history of the United
States is something that we would all be
better served to do and I think we would
be bought all better off if if more
people understood it in in some degree
of detail but specifically when it comes
to Empire and the misconceptions that
many people have about the history of
American Empire and also some of the
confusions between Empire and
colonialism I think that it's a
particularly important topic now give us
a sort of entryway into the topic as
your book describes it how far back do
we need to go to start developing our
understanding of American Empire I think
you need to go all the way back to the
beginning from the day that the country
receives its independence from Great
Britain from the day that that treaty is
ratified the United States despite its
name the United States of America isn't
just a union of states it's a union of
states and territories that's what it is
on day one that's what it is today and
that's what it's been on every
intervening day more to the point the
the official name of the country is the
United States of America but for most of
the country's history it also hasn't
been was limited to North America since
1857 the country's borders have extended
into the Caribbean and into the Pacific
so I think if you really want to
understand US history you need to
understand the full scope of the United
States and you need to understand that
that means not just looking at the
state's not just looking at the
contiguous blob but looking at the US
Empire yeah so let's start maybe a
little bit with the islands in the
Pacific and the Caribbean and
interestingly the role that that guano
or
who plays in all of this and if people
of my generation I think we hear the
word guano and they think of Jim Carrey
and they think of one of those Ace
Ventura movies where where that was the
first time I was exposed to guano when I
was like nine years old or something
like that but this is actually not just
a joke from a Jim Carrey movie this is
actually connected to a lot of really
important historical issues for the
United States in the Caribbean and in
the Pacific how did how does that work
what's the role of guano yeah so let's
talk about what guano is guano is either
bat or bird feces that's used as
fertilizer and in the nineteenth century
as farms in the United States were
experiencing what farmers then called
soil exhaustion losing a lot of
nutrients as they transition to
industrial agriculture but didn't yet
have the chemical fertilizers that we
have they found that they were
encountering decreasing yields in such a
way that it was a major looming economic
crisis the one thing that worked that
worked really well was guano and
particularly bird droppings from sea
Islands so you have to imagine these
islands sort of surrounded by large
bodies of water small islands and birds
congregate on them and then you know
over the years over the centuries the
bird droppings concentrated on these
small islands accumulate pile high into
the Sun bake in the Sun this works best
on islands where there's very little
rain and you know sort of the very rock
of the island itself is calcified bird
droppings that stuff is tremendous for
farms and there's a sort of land rush in
the nineteenth century for the United
States to claim as many uninhabited
guano Islands as I can so over the
course of the second half the nineteenth
century and this is its first form of
overseas expansion the United States
claims nearly 100 guano islands in the
Pacific and in the Caribbean so now
there's a very particular political
divide on the concept of American Empire
and a lot of that divide splits pretty
cleanly depending on where one sort of
is on the political spectrum in thinking
back to the the guano heiress
to speak and the time where we were
seeing westward expansion within the
what is now the contiguous 48 states in
the 19th century the expansion was
starting into the Caribbean in Pacific
Islands was there an equivalent
political split amongst the population
in terms of who supported this island
expansion and who did not or were
political circumstances different such
that that debate wasn't really taking
place no there really was a debate
throughout the 19th century as the
United States as borders expanded
westward even before it started to
expand overseas expansion was
contentious and generally the two poles
of contention not the only ones but the
main ones were between expansionist who
wanted to see the borders of the United
States grow and who wanted to Cley new
lands for the for the country and
racists who were concerned about
incorporating too many people who were
perceived as non-white into the Union so
it's an interesting moment when the
United States expands quite a lot over
the course of the 19th century but
actually doesn't incorporate a large
number of people as a percentage of its
own population and a lot of the borders
of the United States when it's expanding
in the 19th century are carefully
curated so the United States can claim
for example as much of Mexico as it can
get while still claiming as few Mexicans
as it can and this comes up in the
debate about the guano Islands one thing
that gets that guano Islands act through
Congress is the proviso that any guano
islands that are claims the United
States has to be uninhabited so this can
be land that can be added to the United
States and new locations that will be
part of the United States but they won't
bring new peoples into the Union so the
idea of the peoples into the Union is
interesting because one of the things
that I I would argue and you might agree
you might disagree has sort of changed
in the conversation about American
Empire since the 1800s that that you and
I have been talking about so far is that
I think today one of the most sort of
important elements of American Empire is
socio-cultural empire the idea of
music movies television literature when
I go and visit I was born in Argentina
when I go visit my family in Argentina
there's an awareness of that spread of
American empire that is not reciprocal
in the United States from most other
countries what is your sense of the
importance of that today is it a form of
empire and when did this sort of start
to shift would you say yes so there's a
debate now about whether it's proper to
characterize the United States as an
empire and there are a lot of aspects
that you could note if you wanted to
make that argument one is the extent of
US culture and the way that that's non
reciprocal that if you're in Argentina
you end up knowing a lot more about us
music and if you're in the United States
and you're thinking about Argentinian
music it's also in terms of the US
military involvement in dozens of
countries you know at any one time
around the world the polite term for
this or the positive term for this would
be influence leadership a critical or
negative term often used as a pejorative
would be Empire margin is a little
different it's not about whether the
United States is behaving badly is
imposing itself on other countries I
just followed the territory and I just
looked at the territorial shape of the
United States and make a fairly obvious
you know observation that the United
States has had territories and
particularly overseas territories for
the bulk of its history so in that sort
of analytical sense it's it's just you
know on the map the United States is an
empire and I think it's that's important
to note because the territorial extent
of the United States has often been
important in to supporting the other
kinds of influence or power extension or
empire that the United States has been
able to exert in the world particularly
in the last 50 or 60 years yeah I think
the debate is interesting even within
the sort of space on the left that I
occupy in my program occupies because I
think that you can first of all it's
perfectly fair to make a critique in
terms of what ought or should be
American foreign policy and that that's
a great conversation to have but I do
think some of the areas of sort of
question in terms of modern Empire would
be you often hear about
the military presence of the United
States around the world it's a very
important thing but I do think we have
to consider in that that for the most
part the US is in places where we're
invited to be and a lot of it is also
connected to shared defense agreements
that may be in place so what when I
think about this as a progressive I
still do think it's important to pay
attention to are we imposing our
political and cultural system in places
where the military is for example and I
think that there's sort of more to it
than just how far does the reach of the
military exist I don't know where you
would fall on that no I think that's
right my sense is that since World War
two the United States is sought to
pursue a different strategy for exerting
itself in the world
it's tended to distant or try to
distance itself from colonial empire
that doesn't mean that the United States
no longer has territories it does and
millions of people live in them but
nevertheless the United States has
declined to take large populated
colonies at times when it could have you
know it fought the Vietnam War and at no
point did it try to annex Vietnam or
earlier Korea or later Iraq nevertheless
the United States has instead try to
sort of claim what I call a pointillist
Empire lots of little dots that are
particularly designed to allow the
United States to with invitation move
its forces do all kinds of things that
it needs to do without ensconcing large
populations so I think there's a real
difference to the kind of projection of
power in a sort of territorial footprint
of the United States today and the sort
of large-scale territorial Empire of say
the British in the nineteenth century or
even the United States in the early 20th
century yeah well I was going to ask
about that next and you're alluding to
some of the differences already what his
store I mean I know this has just
shifted over time in ways we've
described already with regard to
American influence and Empire around the
world but are there any larger systemic
or structural differences in general
that you would point to when we think
about the history of American Empire
versus for example British French or
Spanish yeah I think that the current
day us territorial Empire the big
difference is it's a version two
grossing large colonized populations the
British were quite proud of the you know
hundreds of millions of colonial
subjects over whom they ruled and that
was part of it the British had a holiday
called Empire day celebrating this and
schoolchildren would sort of gaze River
enly at the map and dress in the
national costume of people from all the
colonies that's both never been really a
part of the United States colonial
tradition even at a time when it had a
fairly even more populous colonial
empire limited today and also it doesn't
seem to be the trajectory of the United
States as territorial Empire it's it's
more and more you know pursuing places
that are far from populations where the
its military bases will less likely
great up against local populations and
produce resistance often it seeks to
station its forces on islands where it
can or you know on ships in the middle
of the sea where there's really no local
population so I think that that's a huge
difference between how territorial
empires practiced today and how it used
to be practiced in the nineteenth
century and is that there's the same or
a similar analysis apply to Spain and
France yeah I think that's right yeah I
think the big shift is not the sort of
flavor of imperialist the big shift is a
shift away from large colonial empires
and that's a pattern in which the United
States was a participant never as large
as Britain but actually by the end of
World War Two was the fourth largest
empire by population on the planet
within after World War Two you see a
shift led by the United States toward
what I call it pointillist Empire let's
talk now maybe about some more micro
issues related to territories today and
we could talk about Puerto Rico we could
talk about Guam or other places the
political debate around those
territories is almost exclusively
focused around the possibility of
statehood and typically there's a sort
of partisan interpretation that a lot of
these places are more than likely to
become left-leaning or what we would
call Democratic with regard to electoral
politics and thus there's this
assumption that Democrats would be more
likely to favor statehood for some of
these territories Republicans would be
more likely to oppose it number one is
that actually is that actually an
important consideration when we evaluate
what should
happen with these territories and number
two what do you think are the sort of
primary issues today related to these
territories around the world yeah I
don't think that the predicted political
leanings of territories were they could
become States should be the determining
issue that just turns the question of
status in you know just turns the
territories into pawns at a mainland
political game and I think that you know
for me the history of US Empire has
really just driven home how awful and
sometimes lethal I can be to regard the
territories as you know only insofar as
how they serve the interest of
mainlanders really the status question
is really complicated because it's not
just a question about Rights it's also a
question about identity economically
Puerto Rico would in some ways benefit
from becoming a state there are really
good cultural reasons why a lot of
Puerto Ricans resist the notion of
statehood there are also really good
cultural reasons why a lot of them are
excited about it Early's acquiescence to
it but ultimately I think that's a
decision that needs to be made by the
inhabitants of the territories I mean
this cannot be just we cannot continue
this history which has gone on for more
than a century of the political status
of territories being determined by
people who don't live in the territories
we've been talking mostly about the book
how to hide an empire a history of the
greater United States the book's author
has been speaking with me is Daniel M
revoir teaching history at Northwestern
University Daniel really a pleasure
having you on today pleasure the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
the Democratic National Committee is not
going to allow Fox News to moderate a
debate in the Democratic primary for the
2020 presidential nomination and the
reasons why basically are focused on the
ties between the Trump administration
and the Republican Party and Fox News
Fox News has sort of unofficially been
the propaganda arm of the Republican
Party for a really long time but earlier
this week we had this amazing piece from
Jane Mayer and her investigation which
exposed more of the full extent of the
connections between the Trump
administration and Fox News Channel for
example we now know that Fox News had
the stormy Daniels Donald Trump a legal
hush money payments story before Donald
Trump's election and they chose to kill
that story allegedly for political
reasons we know about the crossover
between Fox News personalities and
contributors and Donald Trump staffers
we know about the restrictions placed on
Fox news anchors about what they're
allowed to say about Donald Trump and
Fox put out a statement that's pretty
clever
by throwing Chris Wallace's name into it
saying why won't Chris Wallace be
allowed Chris Wallace is someone who
should be allowed to ask people
questions and it would be valuable he's
one of two people who sometimes makes
sense on the channel and I'll talk about
the meaning of that Fox News senior vice
president and managing editor bill
Sammon responded to this decision by the
DNC saying quote we hope the DNC will
reconsider its decision to bar chris
wallace brett bayer and martha maccallum
all of whom embody the ultimate
journalistic integrity and
professionalism from moderating a
Democratic presidential debate they're
the best debate team in the business and
they offer can that it's an important
opportunity to make the case to make
their case to the largest TV news
audience in America which includes many
persuadable voters this is straight out
of Noam Chomsky and Edward Herman's
propaganda model okay let me just
refresh your memory I've said before
Shep Smith and Chris Wallace sometimes
say logical thing
on Fox News when the president obviously
lies they pointed out for example and
before I've hypothesized dis FoxNews
allow this as a form of sort of
controlled opposition so that they can
justify that they are actually a news
station with diverse points of view who
hold the administration accountable and
here they are saying that's a bad
decision because Chris Wallace isn't
going to be allowed and what the Chomsky
Herman propaganda model specifically
predicts this is a book from 1988 by the
way the original edition I'm rereading
it now the propaganda model predicts
that you would see some degree of
disagreement and dissent allowed within
corporate media outlets even if it is a
departure from their overall editorial
perspective specifically as a pretext to
be able to claim that their objective
and that there's a diversity of opinions
but it's really very calibrated
opposition and dissent so I'll give you
an example Shep Smith is allowed on Fox
News to point out when the president has
told an obvious lie but you don't have
anyone on Fox News that questions the
systems of power that allowed such media
consolidation to take place and have
allowed the relationships that now exist
between government and media to grow to
the degree that they have you just get
Chris Wallace who doesn't let John
Bolton get away with an obvious lie for
example or Shep Smith that points out
there is no actual crisis at the border
and then Fox News is able to say why
would you bar someone like Chris Wallace
who's so good an objective and fair from
moderating a democratic debate exactly
what the propaganda model would predict
and I also want to mention there's a lot
of misreporting about what this story is
about there are some reports that are
saying Fox is banned from broadcasting
debates that's not really what's at
issue here the primary debates are often
on one network they are not like the
general election debates although we're
really too
on how they're structured what we're
talking about here is foxnews getting a
debate to moderate in the Democratic
primary and I think that this actually
makes a lot of sense I think it's a
waste of time for Democrats to try to
connect with the Fox News audience
specifically if you are a voter and
you're seriously considering voting in
the Democratic primary and you're trying
to get information about the candidates
you're not going to suffer a significant
disadvantage because you can't go to Fox
News for a Democratic primary and one
criticism I've read is the reason the
DNC is doing this is because they don't
want to take tough questions from Fox
News debate moderators that doesn't make
any sense it's all Democrats right it's
not like Fox News is going to bring on a
Democrat and a Republican and give
tougher questions or stricter treatment
to the Democrat we're talking about
Democratic primary debates the questions
in total could either hurt or help
candidates sort of equally but the idea
of targeting in that way I don't think
is actually the concern but consider
what it is the DNC is supposed to be
doing the DNC is not supposed to be
helping one particular candidate over
others in the way that many allege that
they did with Hillary Clinton over
Bernie Sanders in 2016 the role of the
DNC is to help Democratic voters decide
who they want to run against Donald
Trump and to do everything they can to
defeat Donald Trump in 2020 how does a
debate on Fox News help them do that Pat
so I think that this is the right
decision I don't think that it is an
issue of censorship it's certainly not
an issue of free speech not every
network or channel is going to even get
a Democratic primary debate and it's the
decision I would have made if I was the
DNC well just to step back for a moment
is it possible that some of these
Democratic candidates could potentially
convince some members of the Fox News
audience if they frame the issues in the
right way
like if a Democratic candidate talks
about how it's unfair that some of the
most profitable corporations in the
world some of the richest people in the
world barely pay taxes or don't pay
taxes at all I could see
some fox news audience members
questioning that right maybe being
persuaded or if Democratic candidate
talks about how every other modern
developed country in the world has
universal health care views health care
as a right and the United States doesn't
maybe that could raise some eyebrows
from the conservative Fox News viewers
maybe you could change some minds I
don't know maybe there's a potential for
this to be good if if you've reached out
and and put Democratic candidates in
front of a Fox News audience but this is
a primary this is a primary there's
plenty of time for them to do that when
we get to the actual general election
debates if the risk is Fox will do what
they did to me when I went on Fox they
give everybody this bad lighting they
make the room so hot that the candidates
are sweating and they make them look
uncomfortable and not good I I think
you're right and that's why Fox should
televise the general election debates
and then the Democratic candidate can
make their fate their case in front of
the Fox News audience I think it's the
right decision when it comes to the
primary debates not everybody gets the
broadcast rather to moderate a primary
debate Fox News is just one of the
places where there will not be a
Democratic primary debate and I think
that it's the absolute right decision I
have a cringe-worthy bit of audio and
video for you today Donald Trump called
Apple's CEO Tim Cook Tim Apple Tim Cook
is really well known in the business
world and Trump likes having business
people around the White House now a lot
of them can't stand Trump so for example
Elon Musk bailed out of participating on
some kind of business advisory panel for
Donald Trump other CEOs have also said I
just can't work with the guy but anyway
Donald Trump was able to get Tim Cook to
go to the White House for something
called the American work force policy
advisory board and he called him Tim
Apple and I'm gonna play the video for
you twice in a moment the first time I
saw the video I thought maybe I heard it
wrong or maybe Donald from Studdard or
anything other than Trump called the guy
Tim Apple but he did he called him Tim
Apple and the look on Tim Tim Cook's
face sort of says it all you will also
notice that Ivanka all
so seems to kind of like a slightly
perkupp who is for whatever reason there
as usual I don't know why she's there
Jared Kushner's they are unelected and
not confirmed by the Senate advisors but
okay they are there here is Donald Trump
referring to Tim Cook as Tim Apple we
appreciate it very much Jim Apple but we
appreciate it very much Tim Apple but
this is just the best and hilariously
this is this has happened before
once Donald Trump had some kind of event
with Lockheed Martin's CEO Marilyn
Hewson and he referred to her as Marilyn
Lockheed check it out we have some of
our great business leaders and leaders
period right behind me I may ask Marilyn
Lockheed the leading woman's business
executive in this country according to
many this is just the best of course
she's the leading business executive of
women's business executive in the
country according to many more people
who actually know her real name rather
than Marilyn Lockheed is it possible
that Trump thinks since his businesses
are all called Trump whatever that every
business is named after the person
that's running the business or something
like that there's a report that Bill
Microsoft is now refusing to even meet
with the president after this incident
and Mark Facebook Berg is going to have
to face really tough questions from
Trump at the White House very very soon
I read something that's kind of an
interesting take on this which is that
this is a either conscious or
unconscious sort of psychological
domination game that Donald Trump is
playing that it is a way of showing that
he doesn't even need to call people by
the right name that to him they are
simply the CEO of the company
you're basically Tim Apple you're just
Tim the CEO of Apple you're Marilyn
Lockheed as he said it doesn't matter
what your actual last name is you're
just Marilyn the CEO of Lockheed Martin
it's an interesting
take but I think the more realistic
scenario is that this is part of the
cognitive decline that so many people
have been observing in Donald Trump in
which we will be following up on with a
psychiatrist dr. John Gartner very soon
sooner than then before you know it
John Gartner will be back on the program
we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p very
interesting voicemail about the criminal
justice system that came in take a
listen to this one hi David my name is
Lindsey I live in Tampa Florida I was
listening to your interview and was just
kind of wondering what the effects on
the criminal justice system will be if
all of those low-level offenders pled
not guilty what kind of effect would it
have on I mean the whole court system
from low-level misdemeanors all the way
up to high-level felonies but what you
get a salutely fantastic question
absolutely fantastic question
the criminal justice system the court
system would grind to a halt if they
lost the benefit of what I call the plea
deal industrial complex where most
charges do not lead to trials and it is
something that I've read sort of
extensively about if you actually were
able to get the resources for a lot of
these defendants and if the sort of
economic circumstances didn't prevent
them from just having to take a plea
deal and you got more not guilty pleas
it would grind the system to a halt in
such a an acute way that there would be
no choice but to reform the system and
to change how it functions but
unfortunately it all benefits from the
fact that a lot of defendants don't have
the financial resources to do it and
that for other reasons it's also
extraordinarily difficult but very very
good question we've got a tremendous
bonus show for you today we will talk
about a house democratic investigation
into voter suppression in Florida we've
been calling for this since the midterm
election and
is actually starting up the citizenship
question has been blocked from the 2020
census that's good news and we will talk
about it and lastly uber has been found
not criminally liable in the death of
the woman who was hit by a self-driving
car which we reported on extensively up
until this point that is according to a
prosecutor and we will talk about all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show speak to you them
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you